[Applaudissements]
mcttar il y a des histoires d'argent
entre Mtar et moi ça je ne l'accepterai
jamais hier il me dit ça fait des
semaines que tu ça fait des années même
que tu me dois 10
balles j'ai dit moi je devrais 10 balles
à Moctar c'est des chaussettes je te
dois 10 balles non mais frère hier
c'était 10 balles aujourd'hui c'est 50
balles non mais tuas un taré toi c'est
quoi tes intérêts ça un jour ça été
multiplié par 5 demain je te dois 10
balles non je te dois 10 ball c'est quoi
l'objet du truc B j'ai les gars
amenez-moi un jeu n'importe lequel de la
boule de pétanque même de la boule même
pas de pétanque de la boule amenez-moi
n'importe quel jeu n'importe ce que vous
trouvez on va faire un pareil avec
Moktar tout de suite on va all remettre
en jeu c'est 10 balles hier tu m'as dit
10 balles non non mais frère arrête un
peu non mais je suis pas tes copains les
on mais attendez Cyr pardonnez-moi Cyr
pardonnez-moi parce que vous lui devez
50 balles et vous remettez en jeu de
l'argent que vous lui avez pas donné i
oui oui oui
vaag je te dois 50 balles si c'est 50
mais frère tu m'as dit 10 balles hier
non mais j'ai menti c'est 50 comment ah
tu as menti tuas menti alors alors le
gars le gars il m mais en en sa faveur
non mais tu es une cadar toi frère donc
hier tu me dis 10 balles aujourd'hui 50
balles c'est combien non 50 sérieux non
frère ça vient d'où ça vient d'O 10
balles ça VI mais tout le monde était là
qu'on a été ça vient c'est qu'on était
Stade Français là c'est quoi quand voulu
tirer avec la raquette tuavais loupé
trois fois ah
ouioui ah c'était 10 balles c'était pas
10 balles pas 50
ball prgénérique non ramène-moi des
boules il y a des boules de pétantes les
boules molles tu en as déjà dans le
slip c'est bon tu veux parier sur quoi
ce que tu veux
pourquoi tu sais que toi tu me dois tu
me devais 200 balles quoi je donné je
par chercher avec mais je les ai jamais
vu tu es parti les chercher mais
je c'était un test pour voir s'il avait
bonne mémoire bravo donc tu me dois 50
j'ai pas menti non je te dois 10 balles
si tu veux je te lois 50 balles et ben
tu sais ce qu'on fait on fait un jeu
vas-y si tu perds ouais je te dois 100
balles tu les don t'inquiète si tu
gagnes t'inquiète pas je les aur si tu
gagnes je te dois 100 balles par contre
si tu perds tu me dois 150
balles
non attends attends attends attends
attends on fait fait un autre truc si tu
gagnes tu gagne 100 balles si je gagne
je gagne 50 balles vas-y on est d'accord
c'est bon vas-y c'est fait c'est fait
AMZ n'importe on va amener n'importe
quoi n'importe quel jeu mec à la base on
lu don n'impor quel je non tu veux quoi
tu veux non mais on va faire un jeu tu
veux un jeu du téléphone la poubelle
hein tu veux le jeu du
téléphoneb poubelle c'est bien mais vous
savez que vous pouvez retrouver les
images parce que moi je me souviens
cétait un prégénérique au Stade Français
sur le paddle on était tous là mctar est
arrivé en femme me semble-til très belle
femme très belle femme très belle et
vous deviez le toucher effectivement
c'est 50 € en jeu et vous avez pas
touché oui c'est donc les images à mon
avis peuvent prouver que je pense après
est vu en FEM je par du postulat c'est
50 balles ok très bien il gagne le jeu
il a 100 balles il perd le jeu il me
donne 50 balles pas compliquéou très
bien par contre tu les as toi comment tu
tu
péges tuées excuse-moimi dire ça tu bég
non mais je te le dis est-ce que tu as
ces 50 balles je peux les avoir peux les
avoir je peux les avoir depis 5 mois
vous pouvez pas sonter de jours quand
même c'est c'est elle qui m'a soufflé
c'est elle qui m'a soufflé moi je
voulais pas le dire fais-toi tout petit
non franchement fais-toi tout petit non
non excusez-moi Cyril on peut tous
demander ce que vous nous
devez vas-y ah parce que moi alors là
j'ai gagné trois voyages deux vélos
électriques deux
ordinateurs mais frère je t'ai donné une
bague pour te marier tu me l'as jamais
rendu
toi toii tout et la dernière fois il a
perdu contre moi à Paris je lu redonné
l'oseille vous avez vous avez été
magnanim vous avez dit j'étais influencé
là la dernière chose en date c'est deux
places pour le rugby la finale samedi
voilà souvenez de ça cé il y a de jours
oui oui oui do vous avoir deux places
pour aller voir le mais c'est vous qui
avez proposé gentiment j'ai rien demandé
mais çai c'est bientôt là là où je
voulais en venir j'ai rien demandé
j'appelle Bernard la porte la semainee
mais j'appelle Bernard la porte je voir
s'il peut il y avait pas un resto aussi
avec il est même pas invité Bernard qui
la porte y aller au resto il la
porte non voulez que j'appelle je va
apper le patron de canal t'inquiète pas
je vais t mais non mais non j'ai le
président de la Fédération française de
rugby je vais l'appeler tinquiète pas
par contre si vous voulez que ce soit
moi qui aille quand tu vas voir ta
gueule ça va pas être la même his je
veux pas vous piquz vos places piquemoi
mes
places vous savez quoi cy allez-y tous
les deux il m' déjà piqué Fatou ai
t'inquiète pas qu'est-
toi toi tu es un génie tu es le meilleur
voilà tu es le meilleur regardez regarde
ah pas mal pas mal alors vas-y et ben
vas-y mets-moi la poubelle là-bas chérie
merci mon cheras vu cette
organisation cet homme cet homme
reteneit son nom Alex guerrier et
j'embrasse sa cousine
Xena la guerrière non franchement c'est
vrai mais franchement tu veux que je dis
mon es un monstre qu'est-ce que tu faux
tu veux pas le mettre dans mon labas
chez moi aussi metsle là metsle metsle
là déjà t'inquiète pas non non attends
attends PRS là les mec alors je
t'explique non c'est trop pr c'est pas
trop près du tout par contre alors je
t'explique on fait en quatre boules
celui qui en met le
plus bah si veux on fait en C boules on
peut pas parier nous sur l'utre comm tu
commences on peut pas parier chef sur
attends attends attends c'est par
d'alphabétique tu t'appes tu t'appelles
comment cy non Tonon ton nom de nom de
famille getari j'ai a h G H A B C D E F
h g je suis avant toi
c'est qui conna
l'alou concentre-toi fait une par
une une après ça sera par contre tu mors
tu Mor is non mais tu mors tu mors il y
a e je t'explique tu perds ces 50 balles
déconcentre
bravo
[Applaudissements]
il a raison il a raison il a raison
parce que c'est de la merde on
va on va le mettre là et le premier qui
la met là-bas le premier qui là
parce que
là JIS elle rebondit dedans et qu'elle
sort ça compte ou pas alors ou
ououss s'il te
plat
[Rires]
vit pardon pardon cadre c'est tu te
mets pour tu mors
beaucoup ah c'était bien joué cétait
bien
tiré allez m tu perds ton
slip par contre ça marche pas si c'est
sur le
cadreur t'inquiète pas c'est des boules
molles hein ouais
qu'est-ce que tu as dit comm comme les
mienes t'inquiète pas écoute je
heureusement que je les ai pas mis sur
la tête je arrêter ta
croissance
chariage r ça va rentrer il du vent du
vent l'autre Mar est occupé là s'il vous
plaît non
c'est non il est court il est court il
est court
qui a fait ça tu as lancé ça sur
qui
oh de toute façon cyil c'est toujours le
dernier où il arêt bon chef quand même
tu peux pas fermer ta
gueule ça de ma
mère jou à riention toi c'est ta
dernière vous avez pris la mesure là
c'est ta dernière toi tuas encore
Bou reste encore de et
moi pas c'est toi qui
per je champion tu pas commex championil
y match
[Applaudissements]
champion
gag sinon tu perds 50
ballesureusement qu'on fait de la télé
pasce que tu as dit
non c'est mauvais
ça oh
[Applaudissements]
làro
non non c'est fini
on c'est fini merci
ball allez
on